adrian hauser yeah outstanding work his
last time out he picked up a win that
was against the marlins six innings five
hits retired 11 in a row at one point no
walks 10 punch-outs making start number
two career against the braves
bouncing ball out to urias
and that's how the day starts
for adrian hauser a ground ball 12th
walk issued by adrian howser on the year
ozzy albies is coming up now
swinging a liner to right playable and
going to be caught
by garcia to end the inning left-hander
drew smiley against the call for atlanta
tonight yeah you hope that he's figured
something out from that start
you don't love the four walks by drew in
that start but other than that i thought
he pitched great
wall hits one sharply through for a base
hit
two strike single for colton wong starts
it offensively for the brew crew and now
it's lorenzo kane wong a lead off first
he's on the move they throw behind him
freddie throws down to second base and
wong is out attempting to steal
and the brewers make their first down on
the base pads that goes one to three to
four on the put out
kane drives out a mile high towards
center but right at ender
and there's out number two there are two
down and tyron taylor's coming up 1-1
pitch ground ball out to third austin's
got it gathers and throws and the
minimum is seen by drew smiley in the
bottom of the first inning no runs one
hit no errors and none left we've played
one we head to the top of the second
dansby swanson will lead off we'll count
lead man in the second and a swing and a
foul tip right into the mitt
of the brewer catcher manny pina and
it's a strikeout for hauser is first
another fastball in one out here in the
top of a score of the second inning
that'll bring austin reilly to the plate
right off his knuckles slowly hit toward
third reyes has it double clutches
triple clutches and can't pull the
trigger so riley is aboard we'll see how
that scored braves have their second
base runner that's out number two and
riley and contreras had to stay footed
first and second this would be a good
spot for drew to pick up his first hit
wall one strike two here it is hey
struck him out swinging and the inning
is finally over
abbas saeel garcia will lead things off
for the crew here in the second inning
oh that ball's rifled into right center
down base hit to the wall it goes zombie
garcia on his way to second base
keeps on hitting in the month of may and
avi rolls into second brewers have let
off each of the first two innings with
base hits so the
runner moves to third
and luis orios is the batter now so a
man at third less than two that's where
the brewers need to come up big
especially these spots and a shot to
shorts watson can't handle it
in the score garcia
that infield in made that a hot one for
swanson that's got to be a hit right i
mean that was a bullet right at him and
it was a curveball that
marias was able to center on he left it
up in his own did smile and he hit it
hard and two down with a runner at first
base for pablo reyes bouncer hit to
short
dansby
wow
now that
will be an error i know that
wow i don't see that happen too often
with that guy adrian hauser is going to
be the batter can he hit another one got
him swinging for strike three got the
fastball by him
and that ends the bottom of the second
inning but the brewers pick up a run we
head to the top of the third inning
first and third for atlanta and now the
bat in the hands of izzy albies with an
opportunity to get the braves on the
board at least tie up the ball game
all these lifts one of the air shallow
left taylor got a long way to go he'll
make the catch and they're going to hold
the runner at third
adrianza has good speed but taylor
put it right on the money he's walked
the bases loaded here in the third
inning and austin reilly the stage is
yours you got to make him pay now five
walks through two and two thirds
right back up the middle off the
pitcher's leg and into center field
that's going to score one here comes
ozuna round he will score standing up
and the braves have taken the lead
austin reilly is two for two and the
braves cash in those first two walks the
inning it's now 2-1 atlanta well he said
it walks will kill you so now ender will
come to the plate base is loaded again
64 pitches not through three innings yet
very uncharacteristic of adrian tonight
swing and a miss he got him
leave the bases loaded in the third
two-run single by austin reilly gives
atlanta the lead though to the fourth
it's the braves two in the brewers one
so they do pull the plug on hauser eric
lauer is in so one up and one down here
in the fourth here's andreanza
hey call strike three lauer hit the edge
that one good fastball can't walk it
across any better than that nice pitch
by eric lauer as we go to the bottom of
the fourth avisail garcia will lead
things off for the brewers oh two
swinging a miss blew him away with 94 up
strikeout number three for smiley two
away and that'll bring up urias
and this one popped up a mile high left
side riley gives chase on the warning
track has plenty of room he's now
retired seven in a row when we head to
the fifth it's two to one atlanta
marcelo zuna is the batter that says
great numbers against milwaukee for all
those times with saint louis three-game
hitting streak now a left-hander on the
mount and ozuna unloads first pitch
toldja time for a selfie that is off the
scoreboard a first pitch homer for
marcelo zuna and the braves take a 3-1
lead right down the middle see the
backspin he gets
439 happy feet atlanta adds to the lead
a little more breathing room for atlanta
ozzie will turn around and bat
right-handed he's over two on the night
that is scorch towards center kane going
back to the warning track he'll turn
that one's off the scoreboard nice
smooth easy swing for ozzy albee's
back-to-back homers for the braves in
the fifth inning and it's 4-1 braves
anything you can do i can do better we
go to the bottom half of the fifth we're
halfway home first block of the game for
smiley it's a lead off one at that here
in the fifth inning
popped up
down the line freeman
over the shoulder catch nice play and
foul ground for the braves first baseman
freddie's so good at that play makes an
over-the-shoulder catch makes it look
easy beautiful play and now an rbi
chance for colton wong with two hours
the pitch and a swing and a miss wong
chased it and smiley has qualified for
the win five innings of one run ball and
the braves lead 4-1 the brewers half of
inning number six lorenzo kane leads
things off
swinging a fly ball in the left center
get out
it'll baby a long single for lorenzo
kane but there's a start to the inning
the first hit since the second inning
two on travis shaw is the batter
and on the ground might be two there's
one dan's be the turn and smiley with
his 98th pitch gets two for the price of
one and sends us to the seventh with a
three-run lead and the braves have him
at the corners here to start the seventh
inning one down here in the seventh
inning that'll put the bat in the hands
of dansby swanson
butt is on and it's pushed toward first
there'll be no play at the plate the
throw two first is in time and dansby
and the braves execute that perfectly
freddie freeman comes home ryan sniffers
braves now lead five to one so two down
five one braves and the one one riley
caught it short
marias goes up the ladder to make the
play that's a big one that would have
delivered a run for atlanta to the
bottom half of the seventh inning louis
hitting against the new pitcher jacob
webb
is it high in the air toward right
center field ender on the run to the
track at the wall leaps and he makes the
catch up against the fence we've seen
ender do that in years past welcome back
ender inciarte terrific catch that took
away an extra base hit from marias
contreras with a triple to lead off the
eighth inning the braves try to add on
in the late innings
popped up by inciarte down the left
field line that falls inside the chalk
that will score contreras
in ciarte with a bloop single down the
left field line to drive in contreras
and extend the margin to 6-1 atlanta
that'll be a wild pitch kane goes to
second and here's taylor who is over
three
taylor on the ground kane caught in a
rundown that is
and he missed him and kane's going to be
safe
man
that is a huge break talking about
getting out of a pickle
that is a bad base running move by kane
he knows better but it all ends well we
take this one to the ninth inning josh
tomlin is the new pitcher for atlanta
luis suryas will lean things off against
him swinging in a fly ball hit to center
and deep get up
get up get out of here it is gone
for luis
and the brewers get one back
on the home run by uris
his fourth on the year manny in there
and here comes tomlin pina left field
ozuna
back-to-back home runs for the brewers
manny with a second hit
and it's 6-3
will smith will come on now you've got
kane up there with taylor on deck
representing the tying run two ounce in
the ninth
swing and a shot to center but ender is
there and the braves have won game one
and the braves pick up a game in the
eastern standings